[Music]
they can be funny
pop-up
[Music]
directional
[Music]
hairy
[Music]
or shed new light on everyday things
they're christmas cards
[Music]
companies like delo in munich set great
store by printed greetings at christmas
in this digital world a christmas email
just isn't enough says managing director
sabina herrold
to stand out there should be a new card
in the corporate design every year and
at the very least hand signed
[Music]
we like to write christmas cards because
they show appreciation for the customer
at the end of the year
and emphasize that our partnership has
gone very well
most german companies order their
christmas cards from here carlos
publishing in munich
since june its designers have been
working exclusively on christmas themes
cards for a small handicrafts business
might cost around 300 euros while large
companies can spend 20 to 30 000 euros
and knows the latest design trends
until 15 or 20 years ago the cards
tended to have religious themes or
drawings of winter landscapes
what's more in demand today are cards
with simple graphic elements such as
christmas trees with silver and gold
foil stamping and a short text
underneath
for the year again with minimal text or
the suggestion of a tree
keeping it simple less is more but
stylistically just beautiful
vinegar
carlos has added a website to pick up on
another trend design it yourself
christmas cards for even greater
individuality using simple templates
from the net
[Music]
motifs colors and fonts can be freely
selected and a company logo or family
photo can easily be uploaded
christmas cards are as popular with
individuals as they are with businesses
but i'm also a designer and it's
important to stay in touch with your
customers
preferably self-made or at least a
self-designed card so that it's
individual there's nothing worse than
kitschy pictures of houses in the snow
with golden lettering
which i find very bad
sure i sent christmas cards but only
homemade ones they're the most personal
some i make myself and some i buy but in
that case they should be very simple
creative ideas for the holidays
a chance for advertising agencies to
show off
every year the meta design agency
organizes an internal competition for
the most original christmas cards at its
six locations worldwide
designers try to get in the top ten
because these are printed and sent as
blank cards to customers
meta design spends forty thousand heroes
for this alone customers can then fill
out the cards and send them to their
friends
the christmas cards are a wonderful
opportunity to show our creativity
and i'm always impressed by everything
that happens when we do this
we have for example
this fragrant tree
that you can
we have these glasses that i can put on
the christmas cards boom is also
financing entirely different business
models such as this writing workshop in
berlin
57 people with beautiful handwriting
most of the women spend their time
putting personal greetings to paper
they can do it for no more than 40
minutes at a stretch otherwise the curse
of letters get too scrawly
at christmas especially they write to a
lot of people
something handwritten expresses the
personality of the person who sends it
and appreciation for the recipient
it says simply that you've taken the
time for someone
and christmas is a great opportunity for
companies to address their customers and
send them a personal message
[Music]
a personal christmas card in our digital
age of mass emails and text messages
it's something special
[Music]
you